I'm very tired having COVID. Any suggestions to help me build back my COVID, my fatigue up?
Well, one thing that can be very good for post-COVID fatigue is the clear talks, okay, pulling
that out of there. The lumbar, lumbar, lumbar kinase in the dano kinase can be very helpful for that.
Increasing blood circulation with a product like that and garnicking things like that can be very helpful.
Oxaloacetate has been found to be extremely helpful for post-COVID fatigue. Oxaloacetate is
a sold in a product called Benagine and a product called Oxaloacetate CFS for chronic fatigue syndrome.
So, he tried the much lesser form, as far as dosage, called Benagine first, much less expensive,
too. And I want to give that a shot. We've had some people with really good results with that.
Matter of fact, this Oxaloacetate, I actually do an interview with, okay, remember the gentleman
who owns that company did an interview about a year ago with him. I've been using Benagine for
since it first came out years and years ago. It has been proven to decrease tumors.
And we have a number of our patients on Benagine slash Oxaloacetate for that.
We're really good for bringing tumors. First came out with a study with
Astrocytoma and glioblastoma. And now it's been proven with breast cancer and other cancers too.